[Music]
think different we have all seen these
apples Apple commercials get creative
innovate our society encourages new
ideas and perspectives yet often
stigmatizes people who neurologically
think differently how many of you have
or know someone with dyslexia
how about ADHD what about someone on the
autism spectrum yeah we all do one and
58 people have autism one in 1080hd
another one in 10 have dyslexia and we
have always been there logically
different yet our education systems our
schools our social norms are all
designed for the majority or
neurotypical mind we seek to think
differently yet we exclude different
thinkers this is my little brother
Steven he's 24 he is a painter a
philosopher a mental health advocate and
also an awesome little brother he has
autism for those of you who aren't
familiar the autism spectrum is a
continuum of traits that impacts how a
person perceives or socializes with
others this difference in brain
development can cause mild to severe
impairments it is a wide spectrum and it
affects people no two people the same
way where's Steven he is able to
communicate and he understands that he
has autism that he thinks differently
yet sometimes his autism can make it
really difficult to connect with others
but I am excited for this time period in
history diversity and inclusion are
being sought after and celebrated brave
change makers have fought the in
justices of other and we're finally
seeing and appreciating the value of our
differences there is a long way to go
across previous divides around race
gender and sexual orientation yet I
don't see inclusion as zero-sum and I'd
love to add to this rich conversation
the concept of neuro diversity neuro
diversity is a term first coined in 1988
by Judy singer the Australian
sociologist and it is a concept that
regards individuals with differences in
brain function and behavioral traits as
part of the normal variation in the
human population because like bio
diversity that accounts for the rich
vibrance in our natural environment
neurodiversity accounts for the fact
that all of our brains are
neurologically distinct whether it is
autism ADHD or another neuro divergency
we really all do think differently I
fell in love with this term because it
doesn't focus first on impairment
my hope is that through the lens of
neurodiversity we can celebrate each
other's differences and see the person
first and not the disability or
different ability my hope is to increase
your awareness your understanding and
encourage inclusion to build narrow
diverse communities because you can't
have inclusion without increasing your
understanding and this understanding
requires a broader awareness without
these three elements if you interact
with a neurologically different person
you may be thinking to yourselves things
like what a weirdo
what a pity this isn't my problem these
thoughts I'd love to change instead into
a conversation where we build
relationship I'd like to take you
through my own journey and all three of
these stuff let's start with awareness
as I shared I grew up in a neurodiverse
home through conversations with my
brother I learned a lot around how
autism affects him and also through
seeing how other people treat him when
we're in public if Steven is feeling
overwhelmed in his environment because
of the sensory changes with autism to
cope or soothe he'll paced back and
forth he may seem as arms or scratches
head repeatedly and I watched how others
respond to this behavior I've seen even
neighbors move away maybe to the other
side of the street even shield their
children from my brother and I wonder if
they think what bullies have called him
his whole life
or said to him
what a weirdo yet I believe all these
people to be good people and that if
they understood he was different or how
he was different if they were aware of
the differences of neurodiversity
and autism then instead they would start
a conversation they would say hello how
are you
the next step is understanding I spent
my summer living in intentionally
inclusive community where neuro-diverse
people live together and shared housing
and life and I found even myself
thinking this what a pity what a pity
that my new roommates have challenges
around things that I take for granted
every day and when it comes to different
abilities this can be the default but it
doesn't have to be our default my
understanding increased as I built real
relationships with people different from
myself I met Nadia and we went dancing
all night long and Marie whose love of
music took us to the local music school
for lessons and my neurodivergent friend
Carrie who despite being only able to
communicate through eye blinks got her
best friend laughing up a storm every
single day I learned through my
understanding that I was wrong to start
from a place of pity and instead I want
to start from a place of curiosity
expecting connection the late ability
and friendship I started saying who are
you instead the next step is inclusion
I'd like you to meet Cole Cole is the
president of spectrum autism at the
University of Berkeley
and when he joined the autism Club he
found himself to be the only autistic
person in it think for a moment if our
women and management group here were led
by a man or if there were no women in it
yeah Cole shared with me his story and
his journey to college and how at times
he would hide his autism to avoid stigma
and how difficult this made building
genuine community so when he arrived at
Cal and met students interested in
building narrow diverse communities
he was embraced and now he's leading the
charge for inclusion there he says I am
the first president of spectrum autism
at Cal but I will not be the last with
all the challenges we have in the world
today it's not uncommon to think this
that this is not my problem this is not
my issue this is not my community
whether it is in our schools in our work
certainly in our neighborhoods
there are neurodivergent people
everywhere and oftentimes especially
with the challenges of connecting with
autism there's a lot of isolation how
can we take one step closer and make it
a little easier to connect how can we
change this is not my problem - this is
my opportunity and we are in this
together hopefully I have increased your
awareness increased your understanding
and encouraged you to think a little
differently about inclusion how do you
start just say hello how are you who are
you we are in this together
you
[Applause]
[Music]